premier geste prudent sortir de votre
sac la bombe aérosol et vaporisez
soigneusement sur tout le corps le
produit solaire protecteur et hydratant
en 1961 la mode est clairement au
bronzage mais la crème solaire et déjà
recommandé quiberon sera le mieux la
compétition est ouverte mesdames à vous
de jouer une compétition qu'on a
rapidement arrêté de prendre à la
rigolade
car dès les années 70 on se demande bien
de quoi sont composés les crèmes
solaires vous connaissez la composition
du produit que vous utilisez pas du tout
très honnêtement non et à l'époque une
crème solaire fait fureur dans ma vie
maintenant de même de cette crème à vous
savez que l'on achète la grande folie à
saint-trop' savait que quelquefois ces
produits contiennent des composants
compte par exemple essence de bergamote
qui sont dangereuses pour leur ai
dit vous parce que moi je suis en train
de me mettre justement pas créés dans le
solaire à la bergamote cette crème a les
sons de bergamote et vendu comme une
protection solaire et comme un
facilitateur de bronzage aux votes des
cas de brûlures ou d'allergies sont
déclarés en 1987 l'état interdit la
publicité pour ce produit mais passe
avant cette plante qui contient du port
allen permet d'accélérer le bronzage en
évitant les coups de soleil le port
allen a déjà été mise en cause il y a
dix ans il provoquerait dans certains
cas des brûlures et des examens on parle
même de cancers un concert à cause d'une
crème solaire cette prise de conscience
amène dans les années 90 et 2000 a
étudié la composition de ses produits
cosmétiques et quand on cherche on
trouve en 2008 alerte les crèmes
solaires contiennent des nanoparticules
des molécules artificielle extrêmement
petit de l'ordre d'un nanomètre soit un
milliardième de mètre cent mille fois
plus fin qu'un cheveu et cette crème
solaire par exemple utilise des
nanoparticules de titane pour filtrer
les uv se pose la question de la
pénétration à travers la peau ou de
l'ingestion accidentelle si vous en avez
sur les doigts vous mettez les doigts
dans la bouche boîte et la liste des
ingrédients dangereux s'allonge n'ai
encore malheureusement dans certaines
crèmes des ingrédients problématiques
comme des ingrédients qui sont
soupçonnés d'être des perturbateurs
endocriniens ces ingrédients à bannir
selon le magazine les ti l'éxil mais
toxines amat et le cycloparc phase iib
loxam des risques pour l'homme mais
aussi pour l'environnement chaque été
des milliers de tonnes de résidus de
crème solaire sont déversés dans les
océans les crèmes solaires chimiques
impacte directement les coraux certaines
molécules comme l'oxybenzone le dioxyde
2 1 cuil oxyde de titane les blanchisse
et les font mourir face à ce constat de
nouvelles crèmes sont proposés aux
consommateurs
naturel et respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]